it is Friday again which means you can
save time on reading all of this week's
gaming news by watching this three to
four minute video easy let's go the kid
you deleted other people saved in
destiny may have won the title of this
week's jack in gaming but here the close
second an artist / gamer / freaking
terrible person with too much money
microwaved a gorgeous Majora's Mask 3ds
XL the limited edition handheld consoles
are going for 400 bucks + on ebay but if
you'd prefer to have an unplayable one
that's Grissom and burned you could have
bought it for eleven thousand three
hundred and fifteen dollars on ebay from
user perfectly made birds or you could
buy like 28 non microwaved limited
edition consoles if you're among the
three people who think this is cool the
seller also has listed a melted iphone 6
plus and a 2d s for thousands of dollars
apiece
GTA 5 for pc was delayed again this week
lucky for rockstar their pc fans are
pretty patients mostly the game was
originally going to come out in late
2014 3 delays later and here we are with
a new release date of april 14 of this
year rockstar have said our apologies to
PC gamers worldwide who's been counting
down the days until the launch of the
game but a bit more time is needed to
ensure that the game is as polished as
possible Rockstar have given players an
extra 200 grand of GTA online money to
soften the blow so I guess you can look
forward to that because free things are
the best things here's the free things
you can get your hands on this week
Microsoft's games with gold titles are
coming and they really are getting so
much better in March for xbox 360 you'll
be able to get the tomb raider reboot
for free from much 12 15 which is a damn
fantastic game I just finished later on
march 16 231 will offer you a free copy
of bioshock infinite if you got an xbox
one you can grab yourself Rayman legends
for free throughout the month if you're
a Sony fan there are a ton of Vita games
on sale right now to celebrate the
consoles birthday check out the full
list of cheap games on gamespot
and weird things that are really really
weird Kanye West's making a video game
about his deceased mother the super
famous rapper told power 105 point one's
breakfast club radio show that the game
would be based on his song only one he
described it as quote the idea is that
it's my mama going through the gates of
heaven and you have to bring her to the
highest gates of heaven by holding her
to the light we've been working on it
for like six months as have already been
brought up as a concern by people it's a
little worrying to consider what would
happen in the game if you fail finally
today holy Final Fantasy 15 info we've
got all that plus a 40 minute gameplay
demo you'll get to play the demo on
March 17 the full game is about sixty
percent done right now and the target
resolution is 1080p at 30 frames per
second on top of that the games full map
is set to be 10 to 20 times larger the
more players will have access to in the
demo according to director Hajime Tabata
the demo will unfortunately not feature
the weather effects that will appear in
the final version there's so much more
info and a huge demo video to watch so
if you're keen to know all the things
right now you can add to gain spot for
that let me know down in the comments if
you're going to play the final fantasy
15 demo and why or why not this week on
site in two minutes goes over what they
don't want in the next Mass Effect game
I argue why we need the game demo back
on the chip thanks for that final
fantasy and skyrim mods takes on the
moon and star quest that is it for me
this week I'll be back again on Monday
but be sure to have yourselves a lovely
weekend until then